I turned 70 and suddenly boom I am not
fit to fly an aircraft according to my
stupid insurance company
well I'll be damned if I mother take
orders from a talking lizard
no honey I don't think that letter was
really written by the lizard of course
he didn't write the letter he's the CEO
no it's okay honey it can be hard to
face the reality of age no the reality
is I feel fine
I am completely at peace with my age oh
you didn't lose something to your head I
was worried people might not notice
because I styled it a little different
oh I think they'll notice oh my goodness
that's not a hat
hey who's the hottie oh my god oh he
looks like what happens when you ask a
kid to draw a picture of a pirate or
that a woolly Willy game where use the
magnet to pull little bits of metal over
ball guy's face Ralph Macchio you look
like you travel back in time but forgot
to take your face hey if I dye my hair
that color would it turn out brown the
hair is tough
shego doesn't really love it